over the last few days thanks to our
world-class genomic capability
in the uk we have identified a new
variant of coronavirus which may be
associated with the faster spread in the
southeast of england
initial analysis suggests that this
variant is growing faster than the
existing variants
we've currently identified over a
thousand cases with this variant
predominantly
in the south of england although cases
have been identified
in nearly 60 different local authority
areas
and numbers are increasing rapidly
similar variants have been identified in
other countries
over the last few months we've notified
the world health organization about this
new variant
and public health england is working
hard to continue its expert analysis at
portland down
mr speaker i must stress at this point
that there is currently nothing to
suggest that this variant is more likely
to cause serious disease
and the latest clinical advice is that
it's highly unlikely
that this mutation would fail to respond
to a vaccine
but it shows we've got to be vigilant
and follow the rules
and everyone needs to take personal
responsibility not to spread this virus
mr speaker the first formal review of
tiering decisions is taking place this
wednesday
two weeks after the new rules came into
force
however i need to tell the house that
over the last week
we've seen very sharp exponential rises
in the virus across london kent
parts of essex and hertfordshire
we do not know the extent to which this
is because of the new variant
but no matter its cause we have to take
swift and decisive action
which unfortunately is absolutely
essential to control this deadly disease
while the vaccine is rolled out in some
parts of these areas the doubling time
is around every seven days
this isn't just about rising rates among
school-age children anymore but in all
age groups including the over-sixties
and we know from painful experience that
more cases
lead to more hospitalizations and sadly
the loss of more of our loved ones
hospitals across the capital essex and
kent are already under pressure
and we know that this doubling of cases
will be mirrored in hospital admissions
and it only takes a few doublings for
the nhs to be overwhelmed
our nhs is straining every sinew to cope
with the pressures as they always do but
if cases continue to double
even they will be overwhelmed so we must
act
now to shift the curve because when the
virus is growing exponentially there is
not a moment to spare